later on on the show today i'm going to
tell you that i believe
the left is losing the so-called battle
of ideas but before we can even have
that conversation we should go over the
details of the multiple mass shootings
that took place this weekend with
countless casualties carried out uh
once again by people at least in one
case
inspired by the ideology that underlies
support for donald trump and which in
fact donald trump himself has been
fomenting
and then also a mass shooting carried
out by
an apparent pro-lgbt rights anti-trump
leftist so yes i'm not going to
sugarcoat it one of the shooting
incidents this weekend
was by an apparent leftist but we will
talk about the degree to which we can
say their ideology inspired the actual
violence this is a really important
thing to understand
i'm getting ahead of myself let's take
it piece by piece let's go through the
sick details
now before we even do that just to be
clear we're just
it's a foregone conclusion that all of
today's show is going to be demonetized
for us on youtube and other platforms
because
these are the stories that are not
considered brand safe so we're going to
earn no money on most of today's stories
because we're covering what took place
over the weekend
so consider leaving a tip so to speak
become a member at jointpakman.com
because everything we're talking about
today
even tangentially tangentially related
to these shootings
is going to be demonetized so let's
start with el paso
donald trump has been doing everything
from threatening sweden to release asap
rocky an american rapper
to encouraging violence at his rallies
by saying he'll pay the legal fees of
people who get arrested for roughing up
protesters
he's repeated the xenophobic language
about immigrants particularly
brown-skinned ones
of all types uh from s-hole countries uh
in contrast to people from norway who
are the people we should want coming to
the united states
and it is all now coming to a head with
a weekend that includes a mass shooting
where at least one
shooter specifically claimed that
ideology as his inspiration
the first shooting 11 am on saturday
shooter walks into el paso texas walmart
starts shooting around 20 killed a ton
injured we're still
trying to figure out the exact numbers a
four-month-old
baby was killed the suspect was captured
and not killed
in this particular case we have both a
post from the shooter on 8chan
an online hub for extremism and racism
and white supremacy
and we have the shooter's manifesto and
i know you probably are not surprised to
hear this
but it was yet another one of these
anti-immigrant radicals who was pushed
towards white supremacy
wrote that he agrees with the
christchurch shooter's manifesto
another anti-immigrant xenophobic screed
the manifesto is essentially an
amalgamation
of the exact xenophobic ideas that have
been pushed by donald trump and the
people around him a hispanic invasion
of the u.s and of texas is something we
need to be afraid of
white people are being replaced by
foreigners the great replacement
theory or idea or conspiracy theory the
shooter didn't like
race mixing and it said the manifesto
about
immigrants that quote if we can get rid
of enough people
the uh then our way of life can be more
sustainable it says he was inspired
by the same white supremacist
anti-immigrant ideology
that the christchurch new zealand
shooter was inspired by
and the el paso shooter actually
mentioned
the christchurch shooter in the
manifesto news organizations have
identified a twitter account
since taken down appearing to be the
suspects which includes
the build the wall hashtag stuff a
picture
using guns to spell out the word trump
as well as posts from a right-wing
conspiracy theorist who happens not to
like me
named paul joseph watson known for his
association
with alex jones so in some cases
these domestic terrorists and that's
what they are and that's what we should
call them
if we care about facts and feelings that
is sometimes these domestic terrorists
literally have a vehicle covered in
trump stuff
like that maga bomber who sent pipe
bombs to democrats
sometimes it's simply the end point of
stochastic terrorism and radicalization
that starts with sometimes as high as
the president of the united states
and the white house and the rhetoric
that we see there now there's a very
specific element from the manifesto that
trumpists are pointing to
in order to defend trump which is that
the shooter says
his ideas predate donald trump trump
didn't
give him these ideas and this is super
interesting
they say the trumpets say this
vindicates donald trump
this is not a vindication of trump this
is an indictment of trump and i'll
explain what i mean by that
i've said all along donald trump hasn't
so much
radicalized people he's emboldened and
coalesced and
inspired the radicals to become more
active
to be more public and to take action
around this ideology
this el paso shooter just like many
others already held
most of these anti-immigrant xenophobic
hispanic invasion great replacement
ideas before
donald trump what donald trump's
presidency did is number one gave them
solidarity as richard spencer told me
himself
this is a president that is as close to
what they want as they are getting
and who is saying this is
the time to do your stuff if there was
any time to do it so number one
trump gave them solidarity and number
two
trump made them much more willing to go
public with their ideas
and then third trump escalated their
fear
that this stuff was happening and
ultimately has inspired them to take
action through that mechanism called
stochastic terrorism that i've talked
about before
the argument for me was never that trump
is
radicalizing people who otherwise didn't
hold any of these beliefs it's that
trump has created an environment
where the radicals become much more
willing to do things in the real world
and we're seeing it every week month i
mean i don't know it depends how you
want to categorize it
they're not creating the radicals
they're turning the radicals
into actual domestic terrorists by
emboldening them
and legitimizing their hate ideologies
now
13 hours later in dayton ohio another
mass shooting again we're still getting
numbers
seems like 9 or 10 people killed around
25 injured those numbers may increase
in a nightclub by someone that we now
believe to be
a leftist politically this suspect was
killed by police
the suspect was using a 223
high-capacity gun
had additional magazines with him was
wearing body armor and in this one media
is making
a big deal of how heroic police killed
the shooter so quickly like within a
minute or a couple of minutes
now that might sound like a win they're
touting that as a win and of course it's
good to stop someone
who is actively trying to kill people
before they kill more people
but consider that what this means is
that in just
one minute the shooter was able to kill
nine people and injure 26 or whatever
the exact numbers are
the shooter never should have had
firearms that would have let him
kill nine people and injure 26 in one
minute
that's what we need to be understanding
when we hear about the police neutralize
them after a minute
since the shooting it's been reported
that the shooter described himself
on social media as he him anime fan
metalhead leftist i'm going to hell and
i'm not coming back
he tweeted that he would vote for
elizabeth warren in 2020.
he tweeted that he was upset about trump
winning in 2016.
he said quote i want socialism and i'll
not wait for the
idiots to finally come around to
understanding
he uh is believed to have been a
registered democrat
and has tweeted in favor of gun control
and gun safety regulations
okay so let's now go through something
really important
here we have a right-wing shooter and a
left-wing shooter
and there are elements of the right that
even though we know that the
overwhelming majority of political
violence is right-wing
they are seizing on this weekend of a
right-wing shooter and a left-wing
shooter
and trying to equate and say we just
have violence from both sides and it's
bad and let's work together i want to be
really careful here
but there's a really important
distinction that has to be made
right now it is abundantly clear
that the motivation of the right-wing
shooter
in el paso was his right-wing beliefs
specifically he left a manifesto he went
to a particular place that is at the
center
of this battle around the issues which
around which he was radicalized
immigration and hispanic people etc
an anti-immigrant guy worried about a
white invasion
drives hours to el paso to do this and
leaves a manifesto telling
us what radicalized him we simply don't
know
whether left wing beliefs actually
inspired the dayton ohio shooter
there is currently no evidence of that
so believe me
this is not a show where i sugarcoat
stuff if we have terrorism from
a muslim radicalization i tell you that
when we have terrorism
from these militia types i tell you that
what we know now is that the dayton
shooter
appears to have had leftist politics we
have no
evidence that those beliefs are what
inspired the shooting
we have no evidence at this point that
that political
uh orientation was the reason for the
shooting in dayton ohio as soon as we
get that evidence if we do
i will be right here telling you but
that is not the information that we
currently have as of this taping
and it is really important that we not
allow the rightists to say these
shootings are equivalent in that you had
right-wing beliefs inspire a shooting
and left-wing beliefs inspire a shooting
unless we know that the dayton ohio
shooting was politically motivated
violence
we should not say that it was and some
already are
so that now this is going to get us too
i believe it is time for the left to
realize that we are losing the battle of
ideas
in a very disturbing and specific way to
talk
uh to people about this in a serious way
we have to address this issue we talk
jokingly or satirically about the
marketplace of ideas and the battle of
ideas
but there is a really concerning and
specific way in which we are
losing the battle of ideas and that's
what i'm going to talk to you about next